everybody wants to know what 80s music
you're listening to with Richard Rapport
can you name some bands please
surprisingly this is actually what
they're talking about so I had to recall
a little bit
um
the last one we listened together was
blowing The Wind
by Bob Dylan
okay thanks
thank you talking about the music yeah
do you actually listen to music before
they before the games at this tournament
yeah normally I I listened to something
before like
each day like each game not only here
but uh about my like tastes Tasties and
music I mean okay it's quite quite
various yeah I can basically listen to
whatever it depends on the mood
I don't even I don't even think I have a
playlist
okay do we have more questions than the
Press please go ahead
my question to
look comfortable always English or maybe
you need some translator and second for
both players what is your favorite
movies
no I don't need any translator I feel
very comfortable now but for the movies
uh sometimes it will change
so if I give you an answer now but and
sometimes later maybe the other movies I
feel will be better so it's very hard to
select the one as my
favorite movie
and Young
well it's always like top question so
let it be the reader